DAVE, YOU HAVE TO GET THIS.
I OWE LARRY DAVID MONEY,
AND I CAN'T LET HIM
SEE ME BUYING LUNCH.
- HOW MUCH DO YOU OWE HIM?
- $13,000.
- [laughs]
WELL, WHY DON'T YOU
JUST BLOW HIM?
- YOU SEXIST JACKASS.
I'D NEVER SUGGEST YOU PAY
SOMEONE BACK BY BLOWING 'EM.
- I'D BLOW MY LANDLORD FOR RENT.
HELL, I'D GIVE HIM
A REACH-AROUND FOR CABLE.
- WHAT?
LAURA!
HEY.
DO YOU--YOU'RE HERE.
YOU'RE IN--YOU'RE IN
A RESTAURANT?
LOOK AT THIS.
YOU'RE OUT HERE.
YOU'RE HAVING LUNCH.
BOY, THINGS MUST BE PRETTY GOOD.
- OH, I WASH DISHES HERE.
I'M ON MY BREAK.
- OKAY.
HEY, I'M HAVIN' LUNCH
WITH LARRY FLINT.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
WHAT--WHAT'S THE PROTOCOL HERE?
DO I LET HIM ROLL
ALL THE WAY TO ME?
OR DO I MEET HIM HALFWAY?
WHAT'S THE DEAL?
- WELL, YOU'RE BOTH
GONNA END UP HERE.
- SHOULD I TELL HIM
YOU NEED A LITTLE WORK?
- NO, I'LL FIND SOMETHING.
- FIRST OF ALL, DON'T TAKE JOBS
YOU DON'T WANT FOR MY SAKE.
- OKAY.
- IT'S LIKE IF SOMEBODY
OWES YOU SOMETHING,
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THE ETIQUETTE IS.
DO YOU MENTION IT?
DO YOU--DO YOU NOT MENTION IT?
- MM-HMM.
- IS THERE AN ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM?
YOU KNOW, ELEPHANT POINTING.
SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD,
AND SOMETIMES IT'S NOT GOOD.
- RIGHT, SO--
- YOU DON'T THINK I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW
THAT YOU OWE ME MONEY?
OF COURSE I KNOW
YOU OWE ME MONEY.
OF COURSE I KNOW YOU KNOW.
FOR THE SAKE OF THE FRIENDSHIP,
I'M ALMOST TEMPTED TO SAY,
"FORGET ABOUT IT.
YOU DON'T OWE ME A NICKEL."
-OH, OKAY, FINE THEN.
- I'M ALMOST TEMPTED TO DO THAT.
EH, THAT--THAT SEEMS
TOO MUCH OF A GESTURE.
- I THOUGHT YOU WERE A JEW,
BUT HE TAKES IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
HE'S LIKE THE GIFT SHOP
AT THE HOLOCAUST MUSEUM.
- [scoffs]